que criminaliza la existencia nómada.
¿Sabían que en muchas ciudades
de Estados Unidos es ilegal
sentarse en la acera,
taparse con una cobija,
dormir en el coche,
u ofrecerle comida a un extraño?
Conozco estas leyes porque he visto
como multan y encarcelan
a mis amigos y a otros viajeros
por cometer estos supuestos crímenes.
Muchos de Uds. se preguntan por qué alguien
querría vivir así,
oprimidos por leyes discriminatorias,
comiendo de la basura,
durmiendo bajo puentes,
y trabajando de vez en cuando.
La respuesta es tan diversa
como la misma comunidad de viajeros,
pero ellos siempre responden con una sola palabra:
"libertad".
A menos de que la sociedad se asegure de que cada persona
pueda tener un trabajo digno
para poder vivir bien,
no solo sobrevivir,
siempre existirán aquellos
que verán las calles como un medio de escape,
de liberación y de rebelión.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)